Traduttore: Valentina Alessandrini
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Blockchain, catena di blocchi.
Quanti di voi avete sentito parlare
di blockchain in ogni modo?
Su giornali, Internet.
E quanti di voi sanno dire
che cosa sia esattamente il blockchain,
in poche parole.
È quello che cercherò di fare
in questo poco tempo.
La mia storia non inizia con codice
di programmazione,
ma con una mano di poker.
Immaginate di giocare a poker
con persone che non conoscete,
e di far parte di un gioco in cui
nessuno ha denaro contante, né fiches,
e che sul tavolo, a parte le carte,
non ci sia null'altro
oltre che fogli di carta bianca.
Certo, potreste ritagliare i fogli
di carta in piccoli cerchi
e farne delle fiches.
Ma non fidandovi l'uno degli altri,
avete paura che possano imbrogliare.
Ad esempio ritagliando
di nascosto le fiches
o passandosele sotto il tavolo.
Decidete allora di distribuire
queste pagine ad ognuno,
e vi impegnate ciascuno a scrivere
chi scommette quanto,
chi vince e chi perde.
Ognuno tiene la propria copia
accanto a sé, visibile a tutti.
In questo modo, se qualcuno
commette un errore,
o prova a imbrogliare,
o anche se un paio di giocatori
provano a colludere,
per far perdere qualcuno in particolare,
la discrepanza diventa evidente a tutti.
Dopo un paio di mani,
avrete riempito una pagina,
con un registro di scambi di denaro.
Chiamiamo queste pagine:
"blocchi di transazioni"
Dopo un'ora, avrete probabilmente
diverse pagine,
e avrete cominciato a numerarle.
Chiamiamo questo plico ordinato di pagine,
catena di blocchi di transazioni.
Avete creato una "blockchain".
La prima e più importante
implementazione di blockchain
di cui sicuramente avrete sentito parlare,
si chiama: Bitcoin.
Nel 2008, proprio mentre
l'industria finanziaria statunitense,
non solo,
entrava in una profonda crisi,
una persona o un collettivo,
sotto lo pseudonimo di Satoshi Nakamoto,
pubblica un saggio in cui
illustra una tecnologia
che per la prima volta
consente di trasferire il valore digitale
senza bisogno di intermediari fidati.
E questo atto apparentemente semplice,
innesca una scintilla che causa stupore,
paura e interesse un po' dappertutto.
Ma facciamo un passo indietro
e torniamo al poker.
Bitcoin, è un software
che funziona esattamente
come un enorme tavolo di poker,
in cui milioni di persone
che non si conoscono,
e non si fidano l'uno dell'altro,
tengono aggiornata una catena di blocchi,
tante pagine con la storia
di tutte le transazioni.
Alcune scambiano effettivamente denaro,
ma molti sono solo dei volontari
che mettono a disposizione
la propria capacità di calcolo,
con il computer,
per verificare e tenere sincronizzata
questa storia di transazioni.
Avere milioni di persone che
tengono sincronizzata separatamente
questa storia,
può sembrare un buon modo
per garantire la sicurezza
e l'integrità della stessa.
In realtà, in un sistema completamente
decentralizzato come Bitcoin,
in cui non c'è un'autorità centrale
come ad esempio una banca,
a monitorare le transazioni
e ad evitare frodi,
si pongono alcuni problemi.
Ad esempio: chi ci garantisce
che solo il legittimo proprietario
dei fondi possa effettivamente inviarli?
E chi ci garantisce
che lo possa fare una volta sola?
Il protocollo di Bitcoin,
offre garanzie matematiche
a questi problemi,
grazie alla crittografia,
ed è per questo che essendo basato
sulla crittografia,
Bitcoin è anche chiamata
la prima Criptovaluta.
In particolare,
grazie alle firme digitali,
il protocollo di Bitcoin
assicura che le transazioni provengano
solo dal legittimo proprietario,
e grazie ad altri accorgimenti
basati sulla crittografia,
questo grande registro contabile
distribuito del valore,
è resistente a compromissioni e hacking.
Negli ultimi decenni,
abbiamo quasi dato per scontato
avere accesso al cosiddetto:
"Internet dell'informazione."
Se vi invio un file, una e-mail,
non vi sto mandando l'originale,
ma sto creando una copia,
e non c'è alcun problema,
è la democrazia dell'informazione.
Ma per quanto riguarda proprietà
come ad esempio:
case, azioni, denaro appunto,
inviare una copia è un grande problema.
Se vi mando 1.000 euro,
è importante che io poi
quei 1.000 euro non li abbia più
e non li possa spendere nuovamente.
Come detto il protocollo di Bitcoin
risolve questi problemi,
che sono noti da tempo in crittografia
e nella scienza dell'informazione,
come il problema della doppia spesa,
grazie alla crittografia.
E per la prima volta,
realizza il concetto di
scarsità di un bene digitale.
Infatti esiste un limite al numero
di Bitcoin che saranno in circolazione
e la curva dell'inflazione
è scritta immutabile nel protocollo.
Al giorno d'oggi, la nostra economia,
si basa su alcuni intermediari fidati,
a cui deleghiamo
funzioni fondamentali.
A esempio: banche,
assicurazioni e notai.
Funzionano bene ma
pongono alcuni problemi.
Innanzitutto sono centralizzati.
Possono essere hackerati
e dunque compromessi,
e sentiamo ogni settimana
notizie in merito.
L'ultima ad esempio,
la compromissione di Equifax.
Escludono miliardi di persone
dall'economia globale.
Rallentano i processi.
Ci vogliono secondi per inviare una e-mail
dall'altro capo del mondo,
mentre ci possono volere 7 giorni
a inviare un bonifico in alcune zone.
E infine, impongono
alti costi di transazione.
Per inviare denaro contante
in alcune zone dell'Africa,
le commissioni possono superare
il 20 percento.
E se assieme, parallelamente
all'Internet dell'informazione,
avessimo un Internet del valore?
Un grande registro contabile distribuito,
un mezzo naturale di trasmissione
del valore digitale.
Questa grande sfida è quella che si pone
la tecnologia che chiamiamo:
blockchain.
Bitcoin è una, la più importante,
ma una blockchain.
Ne esistono tante altre.
Ethereum, è una blockchain,
scritta da un ragazzo russo-canadese
di nome Vitalik Butarin
all'età di soli diciannove anni,
e la sua caratteristica più straordinaria
è la possibilità di stipulare
contratti intelligenti
o smart-contracts.
Sono dei veri e propri contratti
in codice di programmazione,
che vengono eseguiti in modo distribuito,
senza nessun intermediario,
come ad esempio notaio, esecutori,
e si occupano di gestione, adempimento,
esecuzione e pagamento
in maniera completamente integrata
e ad oggi sulla blockchain di Ethereum,
ci sono dei progetti che spaziano
dalla sostituzione di borse,
ai mercati azionari, al crowdfunding
di startup, a giochi d'azzardo,
con garanzia crittografica di correttezza.
Addirittura a nuovi modelli di democrazia,
che superino le ideologie del XX secolo
e rendano i politici
veramente responsabili
nei confronti dei cittadini.
Don Tapscott qui a TED si chiede:
come possiamo risolvere
il problema della disuguaglianza?
Possiamo creare nuovi approcci
a questo problema?
Fin ora l'approccio principale è stato:
ridistribuire la ricchezza,
attraverso le tasse ad esempio.
Ma se potessimo cambiare il modo
in cui si genera la ricchezza,
democratizzandola, includendo
più persone in questo processo,
e assicurandoci che ognuno riceva
il giusto compenso.
Secondo Hernando de Soto, il grande
economista latino-americano,
il primo ostacolo alla mobilità
economica in sud America,
è la mancanza di titoli
di proprietà affidabili.
In zone dove l'accesso
al conto bancario è molto raro,
non poter dimostrare
di possedere una terra,
vuol dire non poterla mettere
a garanzia di un prestito,
e quindi non poter fare
progetti per il futuro.
In Honduras, dove il problema
è particolarmente sentito,
il governo sta collaborando
con una società texana,
che si occupa di blockchain,
per mettere i registri di proprietà
su questa tecnologia.
In questo modo sono distribuiti,
sono reistenti a compromissioni,
sono pubblicamente verificabili.
Seguire questo esempio, potrebbe
potenzialmente creare prosperità
per miliardi di persone.
Si stima che più di due terzi
dei proprietari terrieri al mondo,
non abbia un pieno titolo di proprietà.
Il maggior flusso di denaro da paesi
sviluppati a paesi in via di sviluppo,
sono le rimesse degli emigrati.
È la diaspora globale, persone che
lasciano il proprio paese di origine,
la propria famiglia,
e vanno a lavorare in altri paesi.
Ogni mese, mandano a casa,
nel proprio paese di orgine,
parte del loro stipendio.
Si tratta di un mercato di più
di 600 miliardi di dollari all'anno
e sta crescendo.
Una domestica filippina
che vive negli Stati Uniti,
e vuole mandare soldi
a sua madre nelle Filippine,
con Western Union deve pagare
quasi il dieci percento di commissioni,
e il processo dura
dai quattro ai sette giorni.
Esiste un'applicazione basata
su blockchain chiamata Abra,
che consente di mandare
attraverso Bitcoin,
fondi in maniera istantanea.
Alla madre appare una notifica:
"Tua figlia ti ha mandato 10.000 pesos."
Lei non deve conoscere Bitcoin.
Ha una mappa, simile a quella di Uber,
in cui ci sono tanti omini
che si spostano,
proprio un po' come i taxi di Uber.
Seleziona quella più vicino,
o quello che ha il feedback più alto,
e queste persone,
per una piccola commissione,
sono disposte a fare da corriere
di contanti, per conto di Abra.
In questo modo ne seleziona uno,
bussa alla porta
e riceve i suoi 10.000 pesos
in pochi minuti.
Il processo è stato quasi istantaneo
e le è costato solo il 2% di commissioni,
che sono rimaste nell'economia locale.
Credo che seguire questo esempio,
creerebbe prosperità
per altri miliardi di persone.
La grande maggioranza di autori e creativi
non ricevono il giusto compenso,
perché il sistema di proprietà
intellettuale è inefficace.
Prendiamo esempio la musica.
Agli artisti, rimangono solo le briciole
alla fine della catena alimentare.
Imogen Heap, grande cantautrice
vincitrice di due Grammy,
ha deciso di spostare la sua musica
su un sistema basato su blockchain
di nome Mycelia.
Si tratta di un contratto intelligente,
che integra un sistema di pagamento
e definisce i termini
della proprietà intellettuale.
Ad esempio: se si vuole solo
ascoltare la canzone, è gratis,
o costa una frazione di centesimo.
Se la si vuole usare
come suoneria, è diverso.
Se la si vuole usare come colonna sonora
di un film, ovviamente è ancora diverso.
E siccome integra anche i pagamenti
questo sistema,
i soldi rimangono
nelle mani degli artisti.
Vengono eliminati diversi intermediari.
E questo non si applica solo alla musica,
ma si applica potenzialmente
a ogni creatore di contenuto:
video, invenzioni, ecc.
La tecnologia di blockchain,
benché nella sua infanzia,
si configura come una grande
e concreta opportunità
di riscrivere la rete di scambi economici,
risolvendo alcune delle questioni globali
più importanti e difficili.
Ci consente di scambiare denaro
e beni fisici e digitali, in modi nuovi.
Potrebbe rendere obsoleti
alcune istituzioni,
a cui deleghiamo funzioni fondamentali
della nostra società,
come banche, assicurazioni e notai.
Costringendole a diventare
più decentralizzate e più sicure.
Potrebbe rivelarsi un formidabile
strumento di democratizzazione
delle risorse della ricchezza.
La sua natura trasparente,
potrebbe aiutare a risolvere
problemi millenari,
come la corruzione,
consentendo ad esempio ai cittadini,
di verificare il flusso di fondi pubblici.
Potrebbe rivoluzionare
il mondo delle No Profit,
consentendo di donare a progetti
verificabili pubblicamente.
E tutto questo, un po' in silenzio,
sta già accadendo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)